erst vor kurzem wurden die
nobelpreisträger für dieses jahr bekannt
gegeben
und bald werden sie vergeben wir haben
fünf der wichtigsten wissenschaftlichen
meilensteine für euch die zum teil
tatsächlich mit dem nobelpreis gekürt
worden oder zumindest ähnlich bedeutsam
sind
den ersten meilenstein den habt ihr
vielleicht direkt vor euch wenn er
dieses video an einem computer seht die
festplatte in den 50er jahren brauchte
die us airforce unbedingt so ein ding
und die random access method of
accounting and control kurz alex orlov
vom hersteller ibm macht den anfang
sie war 1000 kilogramm schwer eine tonne
also rund so schwer wie ein auto und sie
kommt dem jahr 1956 mit einer
übertragungsgeschwindigkeit von 8 8
kilobyte pro sekunde arbeiten und hatte
eine speicherkapazität von fünf megabyte
zum vergleich mit usb 3.0 kann man in
einer sekunde rund 625 megabyte
übertragen und eine festplatte in der
standardausführung fängt heutzutage bei
rund 500 gigabyte an
also das ist 1000 mal 1000 mal größer
die remixe oft war das erste direct
access storage device also kurz ces die
vom einer beachtet die nummer zwei die
hologramme auf geldscheinen fahrkarten
oder tickets erfunden wurde das
hologramm von dennis gabor im jahr 1971
hatte dafür den nobelpreis für physik
erhalten
programme werden heute mit lasern
hergestellt gabor musste es damals mit
einer coolen bogenlampe und einigen
filtern bewerkstelligung also es war
sehr sehr sehr umständlich aber er hat
es geschafft aber es sah so schlecht aus
dass er die holografie zunächst aufgabe
erst mit der einführung der
lasertechnologie wurde es möglich
hochwertige hologramme zu machen und es
ist inzwischen so einfach dass es jeder
zu hause machen kann das prinzip ist gar
nicht so kompliziert hologramm entstehen
durch interferenzen zwischen
lichtstrahlen eine interferenz
bezeichnet in der physik beispielsweise
eine eben licht überlagerung das heißt
um ein hologramm zu produzieren müssen
zwei lichtstrahlen die holografische
foto platte treffen und aus der referenz
und dem vom objekt zurückgeworfenen
strahl mit den abstands informationen
entsteht dann das hologramm platz 76
feierte dann das weltweit erste museum
dass sich ausschließlich
programm holografische kunst befasst
seine eröffnung hologramme wie wir sie
heute kennen sind also gar nicht so alt
die nummer drei die steckt in jedem von
uns tief im inneren in jeder zelle die
dna unser erbgut erst seit rund 63
jahren wissen wir menschen dass diese
dna aus einer doppelhelix besteht im
fachmagazin nature schrieben am 25 april
953 die wissenschaftler james watson und
francis crick vom cavendish labor in
cambridge über ihre bahnbrechende
entdeckung die dna hat nicht drei
stränge sondern nur zwei dass ihre
entdeckung auf einer fremden arbeit
basiert wissen die wenigsten
denn watson hatte sich die
röntgenaufnahme die seinen kolleginnen
rosalind franklin mit der kennzeichnung
51 b gemacht hatte zeigen lassen auf ihr
war das phosphat rückgrat der
doppelhelix zu erkennen watson zog
daraus die entscheidenden schlüssel
allerdings hatte rossel in franklin den
neuen aufbau der dna die doppelhelix
bereits notiert für die nobelpreis starb
sie allerdings zu früh und konnte ihn
nicht mehr erhalten
stattdessen erhielten in frick watson
und maurice wilkins der kollege der den
beiden verbotenerweise die
röntgenaufnahme 51 b gezeigt hatte und
in ihren dankesreden erwähnten sie nicht
rosalind franklin erst ihr früherer
assistent erich klug der 1982 den
nobelpreis für chemie erhielt erwähnte
sie in seiner dankesrede
wissenschaft ist manchmal schon ein
krimi und verdammt nah naja ein bisschen
zu nah am verbrechen und auf der 4 hat
wohl schon einige nerven gekostet vor
allem diejenigen die unter euch angst
vor spritzen und blut haben sich aber
dennoch diesen ängsten stellen es ist ja
für einen guten zweck die blutspende vor
rund 500 23 jahren wurde das erste mal
blut gespendet als papst innozenz der
acht erkrankte versucht man ihn auf bis
dato unerforschte weise zu helfen drei
kinder wurden blut abgenommen um den
papst das leben zu retten genauer gesagt
erhoffte man sich ihnen ein paar jahre
jünger zu machen das ganze ging mächtig
schief die kinder starben und dem papst
ging es genauso schlecht wieder vor
ziemlich ungerecht 1921 jedenfalls wurde
von percy oliver der erste
bluttransfusion stets eröffnet wo in
london vor 94 jahren wurde gleichzeitig
auch wohl die mit wichtigste regel für
die blutspende festgelegt freiwillige
und entgelt lose spende und der fünfte
meilenstein ist absolut bahnbrechend hat
unsere welt verändert und inzwischen
sogar eine krankheit die pocken
ausgerottet es geht um die impfung etwa
gender impfte im jahr 1796 mit hilfe der
ersten aktiven immunisierung einen
patienten und der aktive immunisierung
versteht man folgendes der körper wird
erregern ausgesetzt damit er lernt damit
umzugehen erkannt hatte jenner diese
immunisierung anhand von bauern
wer sich bereits mit kuhpocken infiziert
hatte starb deutlich seltener an
menschen pocken als die anderen
der schnitt also einer an kuhpocken
erkrankten bäuerin eine coupon auf und
entnahm etwas gewebe einem jungen ritz
der ebenso die haut auf und schmierte
dass infizierte gewebe der bäuerin in
diese wunde später infizierte jenner den
jungen mit dem gefährlichen menschen
poppen allerdings erkrankte der junge
nicht daran er hatte durch die kuhpocken
auch gegen die gefährlicheren menschen
pocken wirksame antikörper entwickelt er
war immun
auch heute werden genauso menschen
geimpft ihnen werden abgeschwächte
erreger oder direkt antikörper
verabreicht so dass sie nicht die
gefährlichen krankheiten durchmachen
müssen und trotzdem immun werden so
einfach so zukunftsweisend
zukunftsweisend doch ganz sicher die
erkenntnis über die menschliche dna wie
wir eben berichtet hatten ein weiterer
erfolg im bereich der dna analyse ist
forschern erst kürzlich gelungen wenn
dazu vater eben wie die erfahrt ihr im
video oben und ami zu rap und zum blog
geht's auch dahin und kennt ihr weitere
alltägliche dinge die einst große
errungenschaften waren lasst es uns in
den kommentaren wissen und bis dann
bleibt dran